now the big question is will you show up
for that reunion I know it's time once
away about this now we're talking about
the avatar well I just if you had to
call it now would you show up for that
reunion well it's not it's not for like
two or three months so I have no idea
how I feel then rightfully I know he's
covering his face is like I'm enough
with the house last time enough well
they said I wouldn't show up at the red
carpet didn't they
I think it was Lisa Rinna who's tweeting
you mother effers you better effing show
up I mean I can't talk like that but I
was there yes you were there contractual
obligation fulfilled not really not even
a contractual obligation I'm Jillian
Lisa Vanderpump hinting she will show up
for the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
reunion this summer though we're just
six episodes in to season nine have you
been watching you said you weren't gonna
watch I didn't watch I've been beaten up
many times boards we know we talked
about those the whole time so I didn't
watch only because personally it was a
very very difficult emotional time for
me to go through and I didn't want to
read it at that and I actually wrote the
producers about it because you know we
have to write blog right you know and
they said I don't think in in one way
maybe you should revisit that now
because I've come through that she
plotted against me behind my back to
hurt me Frank doesn't do that to someone
you're essentially being accused of
wanting to make sure eat look that why
would you want to do that I mean it just
goes on and on and on and it's a shame
really because the focus was about the
dog the dogs fine now
and I think it worked very convoluted
and I haven't seen it but I don't like
what I'm hearing the episode that just
aired was Camille's birthday party right
you and Kyle drove off right I'm having
it all yes Teddy she's just like well I
guess we'll just agree to coexist we saw
a little different side of Vanderpump in
the backseat of that car
right your guard seemed to be down a
little bit it's in the back of a car
with car with the Lake Superior things
are getting closer to actually seeing
that whole fight at your house yeah I'm
going to say yes I did something if I
didn't do it
I didn't come here to fight you staying
here to tell me I am a liar horrible to
have any animosity with any of them but
yeah I can't I have been very good
friends I'm I was gobsmacked when when
that kind of went down your fans like
usual have been fiercely protective and
loyal of you on social media they see
the truth some have made me taken it a
step or two too far there are some
threats being throat oh I don't support
that at all and I haven't seen that but
I mean I'm on my own Twitter or I post
my stuff in these crammed I don't
support threats of any kind ever I mean
I can't control what people you know
what's the show and their opinion but I
don't condone that
but you know there's a lot of troll
accounts as well you know there are
created primate people look back eg
chatted with a Vanderpump at her
restaurant CERN where she was shooting a
commercial for the series your story
universe interactive game about her
other show Vanderpump rules Vanderpump
rules we are on kind of the tail end of
the season we're winding things down how
would you describe what's still to come
there's a lot more to come I mean this
show moves very quickly they don't
really just talk about the same thing
over and over and over again I mean they
just kind of every week there's
something else happening which is quite
lot to deal with me it's called fan of
potholes and I have five restaurants so
you know of course it's gonna move from
place to place and you see some it takes
apart at the doctor as well right so it
kind of follows me to I know they're
making more shows on the way I mean if
you invite me to dinner that's true I
think you said there might be more shows
on the way maybe that's more hearing
last three shows on the air right now
the most amazing job in the world right
right and the other two maybe they could
be another one who knows
[Music]